this is pizza
now before you pizza purists destroy us
in the comments please open your mind
and let me explain this is zanzibar
pizza
[Music]
many people they only know italian pizza
we call it zanzibar pizza because of the
materials because other materials is
only from zanzibar
like italian pizza but it is samsung but
different
meet muhammad he is the best pizza maker
in zanzibar and is pretty well known
around his hometown i'm famous because i
make the best pizza also because i have
a good smile and so on
oh
i didn't know i was with a celebrity i'm
working with pizza master chef master
pizza anyway muhammad is a fixture at
the foradani garden night market making
pizza both sweet and savory for over 10
years
i make it different to your type of visa
like
20 or more than 20.
[Music]
every morning muhammad goes to the local
market for the very best and fresh
ingredients in order to make his
one-of-a-kind homemade zanzibar pizza
pies
after that i take my chopped chop
vegetable liquority onion green pepper
fresh tomato and then i mix the center
and then i put the mayonnaise cheese and
the egg and then i take the beef with my
spiced masala and then i mix together
and then i close for all sides i take it
and then i put for the bbq
the dough for zanzibar pizza is actually
chapati an unleavened bread which is
also made by hand
i take my flour and the water i mix only
flour and water after that i've got the
bowl big and small
i make like a
small chapati because it's like a
supporter it helped me to carry pizza to
put for the barbecue
that sounds good
[Music]
i feel happy because the
yummy yummy tom tom
and that my friends is pizza
zanzibar pizza
[Music]
you